Americans are so divided these days but
there is still one thing that unites us
and that is that just about everybody is
lying
everybody everybody even the
Conservatives even that everybody is
lying from Atlanta to Washington
everywhere else everywhere in between
everywhere to the West for example at
the highest level the presidential
election you remember Joe Biden launched
his presidential campaign on a lie it
was the lie that that Donald Trump
referred to neo-nazis and white
supremacists and just overall supporters
of the Confederacy at Charlottesville as
very fine people now we know that didn't
happen we've gone through the tape many
many times on that do you remember Joe
Biden's opening launch campaign video
and that's when we heard the words the
prezi united states that stunned the
world and shocked the conscience of this
nation he said there were quote some
very fine people on both sides very fine
people on both sides
but those words the president United
States assigned a moral equivalence
between those spreading hate and those
are the courage to stand against it so
that was not true we don't need to play
that video again showing the Donald
Trump never said that now that got
Donald Trump iDEN rather in trouble when
it turned out that he was lying about
this Biden got in double trouble though
this week when an old recently
resurfaced video came out and showed
that Joe Biden himself referred to
defenders of the Confederacy as I kid
you not the exact same words fine people
the senator made a very moving and
eloquent speech as a son of the
Confederacy acknowledging that it was
time to change in yield to a position
that Senator carol moseley-braun raised
on the floor of the Senate not granting
a federal Charter to a organization made
up of many fine people who continue to
display the Confederate flag just very
fine people who display the Confederate
flag could you imagine if that Joe Biden
had spoken at Charlottesville he would
have said the thing that he accused
baselessly Donald Trump of actually
saying that is pretty funny but the lies
that we're talking about have some not
so funny consequences cities are going
up in flames innocent lives are being
ruined and cops are laying down their
badges who will protect us now I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
some not so funny consequences of lies
down in Atlanta where there was that
officer-involved shooting the other day
the media is going into overdrive
the Democratic officials are going to
overdrive to ruin an innocent man's life
based on lies and unfortunately and this
is the worst part of all I think too
many conservatives are willing to go on
with those lies and those lies are
seriously damaging our country we'll get
to that in one second first though got a
got to answer the question that we asked
yesterday for the comments section what
should shop change their name to next
you know first it was Chazz the
autonomous region in Seattle then it was
chopped now what should it what should
it be next my favorite answer came from
M Lankford the Soviet Union though there
is a runner-up prize to Somalia and
vegans whele all all three of those are
good but I like the Soviet Union we also
have to thank our friends over at liquid
IV you know how much I love liquid IV I
have so much stuff on my desk I can't
bear it is I love my liquid IV liquid IV
I was just drinking out of my liquid IV
water bottle last night is the easy
healthy solution for dehydration one
stick of liquid IV and 16 ounces of
water hydrates you faster and more
efficiently than water alone each
serving provides as much hydration is 2
to 3 bottles of water plus vitamins C b3
b5 b6 and b12 if you're dehydrated try
liquid IV I don't drink a lot of water
during the day and I rely on liquid IV I
love it it is the most efficient way to
stay hydrated
a lot of times athletes will use it me
you know I'm not the most athletic guy
in the world let's put it that way but
if you go out with the boys one night
and maybe have a couple too many Coca
Cola's wake up in the morning not
feeling so great I have found liquid IV
really really helps it is available
nationwide at Target Whole Foods in
Costco or you can get 25 percent off
when you go to liquid IV dot-com that's
25 percent off anything your that you
order when you use the promo code
michael mi CH AE L at liquid IV comm get
better hydration today liquid IV comm
promo code Michael and you can find them
nationwide at Target Whole Foods or
Costco there is a not so funny lie down
in Atlanta this not-so-funny lie
involves an officer-involved killing it
involves the burning of that wendy is
this we went through this whole video
point by point a couple days ago the
Atlanta PD officer that was involved in
that officer-involved has now been
charged with felony murder and other
charges according to the Fulton County
District Attorney Paul Howard we went
through the video we pointed out that
it's a very sad video why is it a sad
video why is it a disturbing video
because it's sad and disturbing when
anyone gets shot regardless of the
circumstances but we went through point
by point and showed there is no way to
argue this was not justified the guy the
the perp in this case the cops were
talking to him they tried to de-escalate
the situation they tried to calmly
arrest him he busted out wrestled the
cops the cops still didn't use a lot of
force he threw the cops off of him cops
still didn't use a lot of force he
grabbed their taser gun cops still
didn't use a lot of force he ran away
cops still didn't use a lot of force
then he turns around points the taser
gun at them and fires finally the cops
discharged their weapons very said it
shouldn't have turned out that way but
obviously a justified use of force you
can't have law enforcement without some
use of force and now because of mob rule
in this country and more than that
because we've given in to a bunch of
dishonest premises this guy's life might
be ruined the other officer on the scene
faces three charges including aggravated
assault the cop now who is being brought
up on murder charges as Garrett Rolf the
other cop
Devon Brosnan has been put on
administrative duty and the rolfe has
been fired already even if he weren't
charged with murder fired again
is that justified doesn't seem so to me
why is this happening well in part the
mainstream media are ginning up the
tensions here so here is one I think
representative headline this one came
from was it's ABC Rashard Brooks
remembered for hardwork and dedication
to family
you'll notice in this whole incident I
have not really said a thing about
Richard Brooks there are many things to
say about Rashard Brooks but I find it
distasteful to speak ill of the dead and
I don't think there's any reason
necessarily to jump into that if it's
not relevant to the story but now the
mainstream media have made it relevant
to the story they've made us talk about
it okay
because they have put an obvious lie
right here Rashard Brooks remembered for
hard work and dedication to family the
only thing Rashard Brooks is remembered
for with regard to his family is beating
his wife and abusing his children which
he was brought up on charges for and
convicted for not so long ago yeah guys
got a long criminal record I didn't
mention the criminal record when we
first went through this story because I
didn't think was relevant to whether or
not he would get killed right that's not
at the the the cop didn't shoot him
because he has a criminal record nor
should he have he the cop shot him
because there was a threat and Rashard
Brooks stole his weapon and pointed the
weapon at him but now because of the the
media lionizing this man who tried to
ruin the cops life I have to mention it
there were shard Brooks has a very long
rap sheet he did some very very terrible
things like beat his wife like abused
his child being completely whitewashed
by the media and said by the way it's
not some conspiracy theory that this
happened it's being acknowledged by
other media sources even in fluff pieces
so here's another one
Atlanta shooting victim Rashard Brooks
as Toledo family speaks out this
happened in Atlanta but some of the
family members of Rashard Brooks live in
Toledo so they speak to Rashard Brooks
his father Larry barb I'm and he says
that this according to the article he'd
come in January
Rashard of that year to meet his father
Larry Barban whom he'd never known in
his childhood so classic sad story
you've got this other deadbeat dad Larry
Barban who abandons his son when his son
is a little kid and so is there any
particular surprise that there might be
family problems down the line there no
of course not these kind of issues
become generational when you have family
but then mr. Barban has the goal to say
this we grew together in that year as if
I had never been out of his life
it just didn't last long because of
racism didn't last long because of
racism I I think it didn't last long
because you didn't take the care to know
your child when he was a child and moved
to a different city it's not racism
fault that this man didn't didn't care
to raise his son it's his fault
Larry bar bunts I feel bad for the guy
that he lost his son even though he
didn't know his son but that's not you
can't blame racism for that and then in
the piece this is the this is the
evidence that Rashard Brooks actually
did commit all these horrible crimes
against his own family
mr. Barban believes officers prejudged
his son by the color of his skin and his
criminal record which shows several
charges of theft obstructing an officer
battery on a family member and other
misdemeanors notice the conflation of
these things prejudged based on the
color of his skin we all think that's a
bad thing and his criminal record that's
not that's not prejudging in the scent
that's judging there was a judgment and
you were convicted of crimes some crimes
very bad ones like beating your wife and
abusing your kid not the same thing but
they're trying to blur these issues I
didn't get to know my son because of
racism no you didn't get to know your
son cuz you were a horrible father
that's that's why okay it's still sad
this is this was the same point I made
yesterday when we talked about the
shooting which obviously is what is at
issue here
we're regardless I don't care how
Rashard Brooks ended up dead it's still
sad because a guy ended up shot that's
why the video was disturbing but we
can't conclude from that that simply
because it is said simply because a man
died that it was unjustified and the
person who killed him as a murderer
especially when we have it on tape
especially when we can see that that is
not the case and so as a result of this
this murder charge giving into a mob
rule that has now become it seems
totally lawless Atlanta police officers
are walking off the job well get to that
in one second first though I got to
thank our friends
over at legacy box I love this company
if you don't want your old family home
movies or photos getting ruined there is
a simple solution as legacy box legacy
box is a super simple mail-in service
and you can have all your home movies
and pictures digitally preserved on a
thumb drive DVD or on the cloud do not
let those priceless family memories
disappear because that's what happens if
you don't take action this happened in
May very close family member who had
died I had all of the photos in one box
I lost them I don't know where they are
luckily I was able to find some more
photos from another another relative of
ours I immediately sent them into legacy
box now they're digital there's just so
great you won't you won't lose them now
I think this is priceless basically you
know you can't you can't put a value on
those memories and you don't want them
to fade away or get dusty or worst get
lost get started preserving your
family's legacy today go to legacy box
comm slash Noel's Canon wles to get an
incredible fifty percent off your first
order
buy today to take advantage of this
exclusive offer send in when you're
ready legacy box is great for you or for
someone you love legacy box comm slash
Noel's canna wles
save fifty percent while supplies last
Atlanta PD walking off the job there was
a massive walkout last night in
precincts three five and six and others
this according to CBS 46 which confirmed
the walkout at 8:30 p.m.
now the Atlanta PD wanted to pretend
like the walkout wasn't happening but it
was so they say earlier suggestions that
multiple officers from each zone had
walked off the job were inaccurate the
department is experiencing a higher than
usual number of call-outs with the
incoming shift but we have enough
resources to maintain operations and
remain able to respond to incidents call
at so it's not a walk out to call out
meaning the officers are calling in sick
I guess coronavirus just got really bad
in Atlanta coincidentally in the hours
after this horribly unjust decision but
it is a walkout and now it's finally
people are admitting that this was a
walk at and of course it was how could
you be a cop right now how could you be
a cop I think every cop goes into the
force knowing that they will be under
some scrutiny because they are the use
of force right as they should be the
police should be subject to some reform
when reforms are necessary the police
should be subject to some scrutiny but
now we're in a situation with the police
where if they do exactly what they ought
to do if they are now fighting a man who
is who's throwing that them off of him
who's grabbing their weapons who's
firing weapons at them that they can't
use any force at all that they're being
told no let the drunk driver go home
with your weapon you can't be a cop in
that situation which is why you're
seeing there was a whole SWAT team that
quit the other day now you've seen the
Atlanta PD you're gonna see this
happening around the country this is
because of lies many conservatives went
along with the leftist lie that racist
cops systematically slaughtered black
men in America
conservatives went along with this too
even though we knew it wasn't true we
went through the numbers we've gone
through the numbers multiple times in
the last few weeks they went through
with that lie because they thought it
would appease the mob and they thought
that through some perverse logic this
would prove their anti-racist bona fides
that if you believe a lie but a lie that
that seems to disfavor
your race or a lie that seems to
disfavor the police or a lie that seems
to disfavor or by I don't know disfavor
the white race and be in favor of people
of color that that somehow would prove
you're anti-racist bona fides that's
kind of a perverse logic though isn't it
you think that the way to prove you're
not a racist is by lying now lying has
consequences did they really think
that's so enormous a lie would cause no
harm I don't think so I mean maybe they
thought it but obviously it was going to
cause harm I called this yesterday when
President Trump gave his executive order
on police reform I said I think the
president's getting bad advice I don't
think that the the response to these
riots to these calls for radical social
transformation is too
buy into the premise that the police are
desperately in need of reform because
they're systematically slaughtering
innocent black men in America because
that isn't happening and when you buy
into that premise you encourage the
radicalism and that's what's happened
now and I'm not even just talk about the
radicalism of the writers I'm talking
about the radicalism of the Democratic
politicians who are now charging these
cops just for doing their job and the
radicalism of the media that is that is
stoking this sort of thing can't do it
folks this is why I mean like I didn't
think that we would see the consequences
of this quite so quickly but this is
this is the consequence of buying into
leftist premises when those premises are
dishonest very bad idea and you're gonna
see things get a lot worse now when cops
start walking off the job I mean I guess
that's the goal of the Chaz and the chop
and BLM and anti feh and all of these
other radical groups get the cops to
walk off the job that's not going to
bring violence down that's not going to
help all communities but particularly
black communities it's not gonna help
anything things are gonna get worse
we're gonna see the consequences of lies
and hopefully people learn their lessons
now on another one of these fraught
political and I guess racial issues now
and historical issues all these issues
coming into play but a little bit on the
lighter side they've cancelled and
jemima that's a sentence I never thought
I would say but they have canceled Aunt
Jemima Aunt Jemima the popular pancake
syrup will no longer be produced this
according to Quaker foods which produces
the syrup there's a kind of irony here
though because Aunt Jemima has been
canceled by a white CEO of Quaker foods
in the name of political correctness but
Aunt Jemima is a black character created
by a black comedian portrayed by a black
model who is now being canceled by a
white person for political correctness
which is an ideology that three-quarters
of black people according to polls a PO
and actually the only group that doesn't
oppose political correctness is white
progressives presumably like this CEO of
Quaker foods we are through the
looking-glass now folks we are living in
a very very silly time most people don't
know that about Aunt Jemima they think
that it's it's a me as Aunt Jemima the
character does come from a minstrel show
and minstrel shows obviously very
offensive these days very offends modern
tastes no question but they assume that
all minstrel music and performances was
created by white people and that isn't
the case the character was invented by
Billy Kerr sands in the 1870s who was a
very famous comedian of that of that
genre that nuance though completely lost
because now you know what guys we fixed
racism we solved injustice because a
pancake syrup logo is gonna be changed
now
I do wonder this reminds me a little bit
of the Redskins controversy for years
and years and years you would hear that
white progressives say we need to change
the name of the Washington Redskins
and was all white liberals being
offended on behalf of Native Americans
and then the Washington Post to their
credit reported on a survey that went
around to a number of Native Americans
and they found that nine and ten Native
Americans don't care at all about the
Redskins they don't want the Redskins to
change their name it doesn't bother them
it only bothers white liberals on behalf
of them when we're talking about the
real racial problems that exist in the
country do you think it's Pancake zero
that's leading it I don't I don't think
so well we're toppling all of these
people and statues and products and
historical things though it did occur to
me we could use the statue toppling mob
perhaps for some good so I've got three
suggestions for who we ought to topple
now that we're taken down Thomas
Jefferson and Christopher Columbus and
Aunt Jemima first one Karl Marx Karl
Marx the founder of communism and the
author of the racist anti-semitic tract
on the Jewish Question
here's just a little quote from that
tract what is the secular basis of
Judaism practical needs self-interest
what is the worldly religion of the Jew
Huck stirring what is this worldly God
money very well then emancipation from
Huck stirring and money consequently
from practical real Judaism would be the
self emancipation of our time an
organization of society which would
abolish the preconditions for Huck
stirring and therefore the possibility
of Huck stirring would make the Jew
impossible
that sounds politically incorrect to me
that sounds like a guy that probably we
should cancel so if we're going to be
cancelling people first one on my list
Karl Marx second one on my list margaret
sanger there are actually statues to
margaret sanger in the united states one
of them is in the Smithsonian Margaret
Sanger a a eugenicist Margaret Sanger
very bad woman Margaret Sanger very
possibly a racist she's the author of a
better race through birth control she
writes the most important problem
barring none that confronts humanity
today is that of race culture it has
often been said and never with more
truth than at the present time that man
breeds his cattle with more intelligence
and care than he breeds his own kind the
draft figures alone should be sufficient
to galvanize the human race to action
for the intelligence tests made on our
soldiers during the recent war indicated
approximately 25% of our population
never attains a mentality superior to
that of a twelve-year-old when we
consider that the mentally deficient
reproduce more rapidly than those of
normal intelligence we may well look
into the future with dismay unless a
halt is called and that speedily are
racist doomed to inevitable
deterioration sounds pretty ablest to me
where I probably should cancel Margaret
Sanger she writes in the eugenic value
of birth control propaganda that the
issue here are mental deficiency
right which she has this obsession with
people who have a low IQ and she just
wants to get rid of them unfortunately
many modern-day eugenicist smen even
work at Planned Parenthood think the
same thing and of course there's a deep
relationship between Margaret Sanger and
Planned Parenthood and then in a 1939
letter Sanger writes we do not want word
to go out that we want to exterminate
the Negro population and the Minister is
the man who can straighten out that idea
if it ever occurs to any of their more
rebellious members look I think we got
to pull those statutes down don't we my
final suggestion for the canceled mob
Che Guevara you know Che Guevara
a communist revolutionary and frequent
subject of liberal t-shirts che guevara
writes in The Motorcycle Diaries the
blacks those magnificent examples of the
African race who have maintained their
racial purity thanks to their lack of an
affinity with bathing have seen their
territory invaded by a new kind of slave
the Portuguese the black is indolent and
a dreamer spending his meager wage on
frivolity or drink the European has a
tradition of work and saving which has
pursued him as far as this corner of
America and drives him to advance
himself even independently of his own
individual aspirations so it sounds a
little racist to me for canceling
Jefferson and Columbus probably got a
canceled Shay who writes in the diaries
of the Revolutionary War in Congo given
the prevailing lack of discipline it
would have been impossible to use
Congolese machine-gunners to defend the
base from air attack they did not know
how to handle their weapons and did not
want to learn very rough stuff I think
we got to take those statues down either
we take no statues down or we definitely
take those statues down and get a little
silver lining in this storm cloud of
mayhem that we're living through right
now and speaking of young men in
uniforms the Boy Scouts now are
requiring a radical left-wing badge
we'll get to that in one second how's
that for a segue Che Guevara - the Boy
Scouts pretty good we'll get to that
first though I have to thank our friends
over at Express VPN you know that I do
not go online with that expressvpn web
browsing without a VPN to protect your
information is extraordinarily
risky I can say with full confidence
expressvpn is the best VPN on the market
and here's why
expressvpn doesn't log your data so you
might use a cheap or free VPN the way
that those VPNs make money is by selling
your data to ad companies but expressvpn
developed a technology called trusted
server that makes it impossible for
their servers to log any of your info
you get really great speed on expressvpn
I've used it for a long time zero lag
it's just fabulous to protect yourself
with the VPN that I use entrust use my
link at expressvpn dot-com slash Michael
mi CH AE L get an extra three months
free with one year package expressvpn
/ Michel expressvpn calm / Michel to
learn more the Boy Scouts the Boy Scouts
have now added a badge a required badge
if you're gonna reach the top rank of
Eagle Scout that was made in conjunction
with black lives matter they stand with
black lives matter and they stand with
black lives matter because they think
the black lives matter is about black
lives mattering which it is not it is
about radical radical left ISM it is
about promoting the destruction of the
quote Western prescribed - nuclear
family
it's about abolishing the police and
it's based on lies specifically the lie
that Michael Brown was killed in
Ferguson with his hands up saying don't
shoot but that didn't happen that didn't
happen according to the Grand Jury
didn't happen according to multiple
eyewitnesses including black
eyewitnesses that didn't happen
according to multiple autopsies what
actually happened is Michael Brown
robbed a store then reached for a cop's
gun grabbed the cops gun the cops gun
discharged he he walked away then he
turned around and charged back at the
officer and the officer justly albeit
sadly discharged his weapon at Brown
there are consequences to lies we're
seeing the flames all around us and now
the Boy Scouts - will require you if you
want to be a good old boy scout - buy
into this radical Marxist organization
there's an irony here in order to become
a top Boy Scout now you must give in to
a radical marxist organization but you
do not need to be a boy the Boy Scouts
letting Girl Scouts now I guess they're
all Boy Scouts now I don't know it's
very confusing there are girls who have
become Eagle Scouts
that's a backwards world that doesn't
make a whole lot of sense does anybody
really believe that yesterday you know
two days ago before the Boy Scouts made
this change and added the BLM badge that
the Boy Scouts tolerated racial bigotry
encouraged racial bigotry I don't think
so I think that's imaginary that's an
imaginary problem
and it's being solved with a radical and
dishonest solution and now we've got
more problems meanwhile you don't have
to be a boy before we get into the
mailbag I also have to point out a great
bit of fun on canceled culture Kaylee
mcenany our White House press secretary
absolutely kills it in the job shreds
Jim Acosta every day makes my heart go
pitter-patter Kaylee mcenany nearly got
canceled a couple days ago why did she
nearly get canceled because she sent a
tweet in 2012
eight years ago about how much she liked
dominoes I guess two to be precise it
wasn't she who almost got canceled she's
already so toxic for working for Trump
that it was almost Domino's pizza that
got canceled for being associated with
her she tweeted out fun fact Domino's is
way better than any New York City pizza
Domino's responded and said Haley that's
one heck of a compliment thanks for the
love we appreciate it you know cuz
brands will sometimes just respond to
you on Twitter that slays is a thing
that happens now so Rick Wilson who is a
never Trump lunatic Rick Wilson retweets
this eight years later retweets Domino's
and says you just killed your brand you
just killed your brand what because they
eight years ago some social media intern
thanked Kelly mcenany for a compliment
well what was going to happen these days
what typically happens is corporate
America everybody buys into the left's
premises they say I'm sorry I'm sorry
weed they cave doesn't do them any good
and the woke my mob moves on and on
that's not what happened here
Domino's responded to Rick Wilson said
welp it's unfortunate that thanking a
customer for a compliment back in 2012
would be viewed as political guess
that's 2020 for you great answer they
held firm coincidentally the founder of
Domino's turns out is extremely Catholic
pro-life you this guy's great very
philanthropic maybe that has something
to do with the company culture there but
I think we can all learn a thing or two
from Domino's another statement I never
thought I'd say we can learn a thing or
two from dominos
here don't give them the premise don't
buy a little lie a little lie that it's
wrong for a pizza company to thank a
customer eight years before that
customer becomes the White House press
secretary which I guess it's wrong to be
that too now for some reason don't buy
into any of that even if you think it
will appease the mob Rick Wilson's
threat is that the mob was going to
destroy Domino's in Domino's said no I'm
not I'm not worried about all that I'm
not I'm not gonna take your bargain to
lie and be dishonest and kowtow to you
just in the hopes of appeasing the mob
you're never going to appease the mob
you're never going to do it
mobs don't get appeased that's like the
definition of mobs
right they they are just out for
destruction and they're gonna get
destruction there are a lot of mobs in
the country right now
that are out for destruction don't give
in whether it's on pizza or whether it's
on the police it seems easy
it seems consequence-free oh just post
the square well remember the black
square on Instagram that everybody was
posting why did people post it but to
show that they're not racist why do you
have to explain yourself to a bunch of
liberals to show that you're not a
racist or a bigot why I don't know in of
these people an explanation the white
liberals who are demanding the black
squares are far more racially conscious
racist bigoted than I am I don't I don't
need to explain myself to them I don't
need to go along and be intimidated by
them and what's the premise of the black
square the premise of the black square
is that there is a systematic slaughter
in this country of innocent black men by
racist cops or racist white people
generally but the focus mostly on cops
that isn't true not born out by any
statistic but so many conservatives I
know they posted the square tada what's
it matter you know it's just it'll make
them will make them feel better will
make them think that I'm like a good
person and and make them think that I'm
less of a bad person which I guess I
think I am so I'm just going to do it
there is a consequence police
departments falling apart city's on fire
politics in shambles the mob
rapacious than ever before you haven't
proved been able to prove your virtue to
those people and you shouldn't have
tried and you don't owe the kind of
people that would intimidate you and
bully you into that way and spread lies
in that way that kind of an explanation
stand firm that in the long run it's the
only way that we're gonna maintain any
kind of law order peace or harmony we
will get to the mailbag first I got a
thank you I got a thank you for going
over to the Michael Knowles show YouTube
channel and subscribing I'm glad that
everyone subscribes to daily wire but I
want them to subscribe to the Michael
Dahl show channel 2 we made it to 70,000
so thanks do you can check out bonus
interviews their segments breakouts
including some new content this weekend
we're gonna have a backstage tonight and
in the meanwhile going over the daily
wire and read all these very important
articles get some honesty when the
mainstream media are feeding you lies
it's usually three bucks a month we're
gonna drop that down to 99 cents just
for you for the first month head on over
to daily wired icon / subscribe join
today we'll be right back with the
mailbag
all right first question from Blake dear
mostly peaceful michael since the
culture is now fully engaged in
canceling anyone or anything with the
slightest blemish in their history is it
time we cancel the democratic party they
opposed abolishing slavery and we're
strong supporters of segregation and Jim
Crow just for starters if our culture is
going to buy into systemic oppression is
it possible to separate the Democrats
from their evil past thanks or it is
impossible rather to separate the
Democrats from their evil past that's a
fine idea
but it just doesn't work that way part
of the reason I mentioned today all the
statues that we should topple and all
the memories that should be erased and
all the the honors that should be taken
away from Karl Marx and Margaret Sanger
and Che Guevara is because I know that
they'll never be taken away because the
people who do the canceling are the left
and the left if they didn't have double
standards would have no standards at all
and conservatives we just were so dumb
about this we just don't get it when we
speak we try to make sure every single
little word is perfect and precise just
so we don't give the left even the
littlest bit to accuse us of being
really bad people it's what I say I
flick you under my chin just a Sicilian
expression for I don't care what do I
care what you guys say about me the left
doesn't talk that way the left says
whatever they want they do whatever they
want they have institutions that behave
in egregious ways they never have to
answer for it if if a conservative does
one little bad thing or even says one
little thing that's inartful people will
ruin their lives for it the left will
ruin that conservatives life go back
dredge up one little tweet from 20 years
ago I guess that was before Twitter but
from a long time ago and ruin their life
based on even if they're otherwise
wonderful people whereas with the left
with with otherwise horrible people if
they do one good thing they judge them
based on that one good thing this is not
a fair game this is not about logic this
is not about playing by some totally
neutral rules that everyone's agreeing
to
the left is out for blood the
conservatives should realize that and
it's important to point out Apocrypha
obviously we do it on the show every day
because that's more or less all you can
do in the world of speaking and writing
you can't you just point out these
things but we need to be able to
exercise we first of all shouldn't
expect an apology from the left that's
never going to happen and we need to be
able to exercise the sort of
institutional power that will put some
teeth behind those observations from
Andrew hi Michael big fan love the show
I'm a 19 year old college student going
into my sophomore year majoring in
criminal justice I had always planned on
going into law enforcement but with
everything going on now I'm beginning to
rethink things my question is what
advice do you have as to what I should
do should I stick with it and just be a
cop in a mainly wide area so if I ever
have to use deadly force the media won't
care that's pretty funny or do I need to
get out and look for other things
because of how bad things are going
thank you this is the worst time to be a
cop certainly in my lifetime and
probably in American history it's pretty
bad in the late 60s early 70s too but
it's really bad now it's a noble calling
we need a lot of cops I rely on cops to
be safe and to give me speeding tickets
every so often which is unfortunate but
mostly to keep me safe but now if I were
considering that career I would probably
pick a new career path right or I'd pick
a field that's related to being a police
officer but not actually a police
officer because of how dangerous that
field is now not just dangerous you
could lose your life but dangerous that
you could find yourself in a politically
incorrect situation and the powers that
be the politicians and the mob would
come and get you and tear you apart that
said it can't last like this forever I
think if we get cops off the job for a
little while if they actually do go on
strike or walk out or something like
that people are going to learn real
quick that we need the police they're
gonna stop talking about the ceballos
the police stuff but right now it is a
really tough situation you know people
ask me this all the time should I say
this at school I want to say my views
but I want to get A's I want to work in
Hollywood but I want to talk
about how much I like Trump I want well
good I recommend doing all those things
but there is a cost and the cost right
now to be a cop is very high if you
still want to do it god bless you but if
you don't I understand
Ryan asks I got on bumble today looking
for someone to I can't even say this on
it looking for someone to do a thing to
me that would feel pleasurable but turns
out you must agree with black lives
matter now to get laid by strangers
should I delete all dating apps and just
look for love at church let me know
there is so much in that question there
is so much because it is absurd that now
when you go on this like app that is
basically just there for people to
gratify their fleshly desires you need
to profess some high-flying political
ideology that is actually based and
promotes lies based on and promotes lies
there's that side of it there's also
this kind of absurdity that we live in a
culture where people just swipe all day
waiting to gratify their fleshly desires
and then some of those people see no
discordant between doing that and then
going to church where you might find
love as well a great question a profound
question probably for a whole number of
reasons it would be better for you to
look for love at church or I don't know
a bar or some yeah probably that area I
totally missed online dating culture I
just barely missed it but I did miss it
I never have been on any dating app or
anything like that and I got to tell you
I'm really pleased I'm really glad that
I'm that's a part of the culture I'm
glad I missed because it seems very
enjoyable if you're a single person
particularly if you don't have many
inhibitions but it you know in a way
you're you're giving up so much of
yourself you're putting out these
pictures to kind of attract mates and
you you've got all these flirty or
explicit messages back and forth and it
seems like such a time suck and I don't
know it doesn't I kind of like the
fashioned way better so go for the
old-fashioned way in most things go for
the old-fashioned way from Elliott quick
question is Joe Biden in violation of
the Civil Rights Act for only
considering female running mates your
show is great
oh thanks a good question we've been
talking about the Civil Rights Act and
if you how you can discriminate in
hiring and those kind of practices
because of the Bostock case that came up
and invented new protections for men who
think that they're women I suppose I
mean obviously running for president is
unlike any other job but every job is
unlike every other job in the sense that
every business is unique and yeah I mean
there's a good argument to be made that
Joe Biden is violating the principles
laid out in the Civil Rights Act because
he says he won't hire a black man or a
white man or an Asian man or a for a job
right but it doesn't matter it doesn't
apply to them and getting to this
question of the Civil Rights Act in
title 7 it actually gets to I guess the
heart of the show today on these lies on
trying to fix a problem with the worst
problem rather than a solution the
problem that the Civil Rights Act most
specifically wanted to address was
racial bigotry and racial division in
the country and so the way that it
fought racism was not by creating a race
blind system it was by imposing racism
of another sort so right now in the
country the only day you are a racism
the only racism by law is affirmative
action and it's not the kind of racism
that we all think right it's racism that
advantages most racial minorities though
not Asians and then would disadvantage
the white majority and Asian people and
this is why Asians sued Harvard for
unfair admission practices it was
obviously what's unfair admission
practices they were being held strictly
on the basis of their race to a much
higher standard than people of other
races that is racial discrimination
which the Supreme Court even admitted
though Sandra Day O'Connor then said we
have to go along with this kind of
racial discrimination for a little while
and then we'll change it later even
though we're never gonna change it later
as we've seen we've now passed the
moment when Sandra Day O'Connor said
that that sort of thing would change
that to me seems untenable that to me
seems like it's only going to show more
and more racial division if the problem
that you're addressing you're simply
replacing with the mirror image of that
problem not that Joe Biden is aware of
that or much of anything at all and not
that he or any other leftists will ever
be held to account from Michael how can
we end homelessness in this country most
of the homeless people are either drug
addicts or mentally ill people are both
I've heard the idea of bringing back the
mental asylums but some of my friends
told me they were awful and it was good
that they ended thanks love your show
this ties in as well with kind of the
theme of our show which is that you
can't legislate away the tragedy of this
fallen world you can't legislate away
sadness you can't legislate away
suffering the left believes that there
is no limit to what politics can do we
can perfect human nature through
politics that's the dream of Karl Marx
all the way up to Bernie Sanders and
everybody in between but you can that
shooting at the Wendy's parking lot it
was sad it was sad because a man died
that does not mean that we can now fix
this problem by accusing the cop of
murder when he didn't commit murder does
not mean that we can find a policy
solution that will prevent all of those
scenes from happening in the future
that can cure a crime it won't happen in
the gospel itself Christ says the poor
will always be with you there is no cure
for poverty as Ronald Reagan said we
fought the war on poverty and poverty
one there is no cure for bums hanging
around there's no cure for people having
mental problems there's no cure for
people being addicted to drugs you can
try to fix it around the edges but
you'll never actually eradicate the
problem and the same thing here when it
comes to the asylums the asylums sure it
seemed like bad places it's like sad
places because mental illness is a sad
thing that many people have to deal with
but is it more
compassionate to let to basically ignore
those people pretend the problem doesn't
exist or pretend that it can be
perfectly solved by everybody and just
leave them on the street which harms
both them and society or would it be
better to accept that there are sad
facts of the world and send them to
asylums and move on with our life and
try to make those asylums better try to
reform these institutions as best we can
but not be so cowardly as to believe a
lie that will actually make society much
much worse that is a big problem that
we're grappling with right now and I
don't see a lot of leadership on it from
just about anybody but hope springs
eternal in the human breast all right
that's our show we've got a backstage
coming up so be sure to check that out
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin fenders
hair and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 hey everybody
its Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show you know some people are
depressed because the American Republic
is collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over the Andrew Clavin show
and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Cleveland
[Music]